mais voilà un an après dans ce même pays
qui m'a offert tant de liberté
j'apprends aujourd'hui tu viens d'y
perdre maintiennent un film sous forme
d'échangés épistolaires entre deux
réalisatrices l'une vivante en france
l'autre au myanmar le court métrage
intitulé 1er février est une poignante
réflexion sur la liberté
mon nom fictif pour sa protection ne
peut pas montrer son visage en entrevue
elle est en proie à la peur chaque jour
notamment au péril de sa vie la résa
triesman mahrez à documenter le
soulèvement populaire après le coup
d'état adjoint
john
taylor de numéro 15 amis on y découvre
une femme timide qui s'épanouit malgré
tout l'hébreu dans la foule de
manifestants contre la junte militaire
il démarre à peine et
reist
mais la planète a depuis détourner son
attention
pourtant la répression sanglante
poursuit et la justice demeure
arbitraire le myanmar est au bord de la
guerre civile des groupes paramilitaires
résiste aux forces armées
pour
les lamas caire la jeune réalisatrice
qui avait découvert la liberté en
voyageant au myanmar un an avant le coup
d'état c'est l'impuissance de vivre si
loin
consterné par ce qui se passait par le
fait que moi qui fais un métier
d'expression et de création
soit ici en se cachant bon elle veut
encore croire changement mais elle a
perdu quelque peu de son optimisme et de
sa détermination et la même vécu une
dépression est restée aux mains de saïda
l'espère huit mois avec ma place ici en
sécurité ce que j'espère c'est juste que
moi un jour ressentent à la halle a même
eu la même sécurité là où elle habite en
fait type honda mais oh le court métrage
personnel de ces deux femmes inspirantes
est impuissant regard sur une répression
oublié ici philippe leblanc radio canada
singapour